hey guys Pete here Wow just a while mr.
robot season 2 episode 11 aired the
other night and I am still reeling
trying to figure everything out this
will be my season 2 episode 11 recap and
review and it will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened
in mr. robot up to this point before we
start I just want to mention that this
was originally going to be back-to-back
episodes like a two-hour two-part finale
and then the network changed things and
you know split them up so if you were
feeling really unsatisfied at the end it
probably wasn't because the show's
creator did that on purpose it was
actually the network's fault it looks
like as a reminder I will do this video
like the last one I will do scene by
scene recap first and then put a
timestamp link in the description if
you're the kind of viewer who just wants
to skip all of that and get straight to
the overview and predictions at the end
anyways there's a whole bunch of stuff
to talk about so let's jump right into
it we begin with Elliot in bed talking
about mr. robot being a silent observer
watching his every move he wonders if he
could switch roles and tells us about a
trick a friend of his used to induce
lucid dreaming to study in his sleep his
friend said he would close his eyes and
repeat the mantra mind awake body asleep
mind awake body asleep he reminds us
that we're in on this too and that if we
repeat it with him it'll go better at
this time we hear a second voice
repeating it with him we see Joanne
addressing the baby to put her in the
crib and we see that mr. Southerland is
there he asks what they should do and
she asked to see the phone again she
looks at the address he got from Elliot
and she says out of all the gifts he has
sent this is the greatest we've ever
received what that means isn't clear at
all but it looks like they're getting
ready to go and find out Angela is in
the back of a band trying to get the
people who are driving to tell her where
they're going these are the people who
approached her on the train after Elliot
got off in the last episode and they
just sit silently in the front more or
less ignoring her fans have pointed out
that the song in the background is from
Back to the Future and is one of the few
different examples of songs from the
movie that we see in this episode Tom is
at the hospital getting evaluated after
the shooting while her boss and another
sir look on she's determined to get back
out in the field but the interviewer
says that she's in shock her boss asked
for a minute alone gets the other men to
leave and then tells her if she doesn't
chill out they're going to force her to
take leave from the force she says the
whole situation is his fault for
releasing the sketch and says that now
several people are dead this is an
important exchange in more ways than one
her boss acknowledges that there's
something going on when she says that he
should get the director involved and
that this could actually be an act of
war rather than a terrorist attack but
he pretty much backs off from doing
anything he reasons that they can't go
off on everyone without all the facts
then he tells Dom about the two trillion
dollar loan from China to eCourse she
urges that they can't let that happen
after what happened last night and he
says they are going to get away with it
the dark army will get away with it
because the loan is going to overshadow
things by solving the global crisis he
says the attack is in the rearview
mirror in political terms and while he
is on her side they have to basically be
careful moving forward he seems to agree
with her the the Chinese government is
involved that tells her to go home and
get some sleep for now he doesn't say no
to letting her do the interview which we
can assume is with the survivor or
survivors from the attack at Lu base if
you haven't seen my last video I broke
down the shooting scene at the end by
watching it slowed down so if you're
wondering about how that played out
check that video and just be warned
because it does contain spoilers we see
Angela in the van pulling to a suburban
neighborhood house that is likely in New
Jersey her captors are still silent and
they lead her to a room inside the house
as she walks down the hall we see that
all the photos on the wall have their
faces covered up they show her into a
strange room with a fish tank and a desk
that can only be described as a homage
to David Lynch they leave her there and
we see that she is locked in a young
girl who looks a lot like what we think
Angela would look like when she was a
child comes in and sits down at the
computer
she tells Angela they must get started
because they don't have much time Angela
asked who she is and she redirects by
saying that the water in the fish tank
is leaking out so they have to get
started now she loads a program on the
Commodore 64 which has questions that
she asks Angela at first she won't
answer and keeps asking
the girl is and what's going on the girl
tells her if she doesn't answer that
they will beat her and pulls up her
shirt to show what looks like you know
bruises on her back when angela asks who
is doing that to her the phone on the
desk rings after she's done talking the
young girl repeats that their time is
running out and starts to ask the
questions again now angela is willing to
answer and the question seem kind of
random to us as viewers they seem a
little invasive but it isn't clear what
they're about so the price is meeting
with the Treasury secretary where he is
laying out his plan to offer each coin
backed loans the secretary doesn't like
the idea and he says that it's
unconstitutional he says that the
president will laugh at him if he brings
it to him and he can't let price give
loans and cryptocurrency that he
wouldn't give with US dollars he accuses
price of knowing this would happen all
along he says he is using the energy
crisis on the eastern seaboard to force
him into going along with it
to simplify was going on here prices
making a play to control a form of
currency through a corporation his
corporation Ecore the Treasury secretary
points out that this is unprecedented
and his concerns are legitimately
justified I won't get into the details
about how cryptocurrency works but just
keep in mind that one of prices selling
points is that they will control equines
production by controlling the mining
server he explains that this was always
the future and the 5/9 actually sped
things along
he argues that bitcoin is growing in
popularity because hard cash is fading
in value and they can't let that happen
he says bitcoin is unregulated and that
it's partly controlled by China's miners
the secretary reminds him that he just
accepted two trillion dollars from China
and price responds by saying that he now
wants to use it against them price also
offers to give the US government
backdoor side doors and whatever else
they want he just tells the secretary
not to shut a coin down so basically
he's offering the government a way out
but this comes at the cost of handing
over huge influence to a corporation
price says that he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the secretary so he shouldn't take
the loss personally but instead he
stresses that losses can be profitable
Angela's interview is still going on and
she gets to a question she can't answer
she keeps answering that she doesn't
know if the key is in the room and then
the phone rings
the young girl answers and then hands
the
- Angela on the other end she hears a
computerized voice that asks a different
question that leads up to her standing
at a door she continues to say she
doesn't know when the voice says the
knob doesn't turn how do you open it she
finally says with the key the voice says
thank you and then hangs up the young
girl reacts if the key is in the room
and Angela answers yes after noticing
the cover of the book Lolita that is
sitting on her desk she continues that
the key was in her fist and her fist was
in her pocket this is a direct reference
to Lolita from what I've heard and we
also have heard this before in season 1
when a young Darlene gives Elliot a key
in a dream once the girl enters this
into the computer questions come to an
end she pulls out the disk it's ready to
leave and tells Angela she'll be back
soon with her results we cut back to Dom
at her apartment trying to clean up and
get some sleep she has a touching
exchange with Alexa which brings her
loneliness back to centre of the story
it's a great scene where we really feel
for Dom who is now in a tough situation
Alexa predictably does what she's
programmed to do and when Dom finally
asked if Alexa loves her she answers
that's not the kind of thing I'm capable
of back at the interview room we see the
fishes died now that all the water has
leaked from the tank and white rose
enters to talk to Angela they talk about
white roses fascination with doors and
the potential they hold before we open
them Angela says she's a terrible person
for hurting that little girl and we find
out that it was makeup actually instead
of real bruises this is an interesting
part because whiterose said it was a
test for empathy or gullibility take
your pick if empathy is involved then we
are made to believe that Angela
understands what it's like for the young
girl to fear being abused can't say for
sure why this is important but it
definitely feels like it is whiterose
sort of speaks in riddles so it's hard
to understand what is really going on
here she mentions setting aside 28
minutes for the talk though which sounds
like forever to someone with such an
obsession with time the main points that
come out are Angela is trying to expose
sensitive information that whiterose
doesn't want her to release about the
Washington Township plan whiterose says
that normally her associates would have
killed Angela by now by her estimation
she should have been dead 90 days ago
which would be the day after the five
nine hack
according to the timeline Angela asked
whiterose who she is and she responds
I'm a woman of time that doesn't believe
in consequences she compares Angela to
an annoying penny that keeps turning up
wherever she looks she says she wanted
to meet with her to try and find out why
she was so important to Phillip price
she says the price is ruining their
partnership and somehow it seems like
Angela is the motivation she tells
Angela that it's no coincidence that her
and Elliot became who they are after
what happened at Washington Township so
many years ago she asked if she told her
if her mother and Elliot's father died
for a reason would it make a difference
she goes on to say that if they were a
trade a sacrifice for the greater good
that they gave their lives to take
humanity to the next level and that
Elliot and Angela are both who they are
because of that event he says that
Angela is at the intersection of it all
and that she wouldn't be there things
didn't happen as they did she won't kill
her but she will prove to her that she
needs to drop her mission to expose the
plan
Angela says that she will hand over the
drive but whiterose says she doesn't
want her proof that she wants her belief
and it's a bunch of craziness I know but
let's just keep going when Angela asked
what whiterose wants her to believe the
conversation changes whiterose gets up
from the table and asked her if she ever
believed she could make something happen
through her own will if she wanted it
bad enough Angela says yes I relate this
to the self affirmations from earlier in
the season but she also says that she's
beginning to come to the realization
that that's not how things work in the
real world whiterose pauses dramatically
and says well I guess it depends on your
definition of real and then the scene
ends Elliot is still in bed and we hear
him continuing with his mantra he wakes
up and ask just how long he's been
asleep for we get confirmation that mr.
robot wanted something that was in the
mail at the apartment and as Elliot
watches wondering if his lucid dreaming
experiment worked we see mr. robot has a
menu for red wheelbarrow barbeque which
is obviously a reference back to the
note book that he kept when he was in
jail
Elliot realizes that he is now a silent
observer like mr. robot or us and he
watches as mr. robot decodes a cipher
message that is written on the menu this
is pretty complicated but I learned that
it's based on a sort of digital
scavenger
that a lot of people on reddit seem to
know about that's called DEFCON a DEFCON
badge challenge Eliot watches while mr.
robot figures out the puzzle and notes
that he can hear mr. robots thoughts and
asked us if we can to which we can he
ends up with the phone number so he
calls it the person on the other end has
a disguised voice but tells him an
address and says there will be a cab
wait he takes off out the door with
Eliot following him we see Angela pull
up at the lawyer's house and learn
through the TV that the equine loan
program is going through the reporter
says that the loans will benefit
low-income people and will help to give
the economy a jumpstart since we know
what price is up to we realize that it's
just a new way for a Corp to get
everyone in a position where they have
to borrow from them again
Angela comes to the door and the lawyer
asked what happened since they were
supposed to meet earlier she is riding
in a black SUV that's not the van that
she was in earlier but I don't know if
that's important or not she tells the
lawyer that she needs her to forget
about the message that she left her
earlier in the day it's hard to tell but
it almost looks like angela has like a
relieve the look on her rider than being
forced into doing it the lawyer asked
her if she's in danger and she says no
they go back and forth a bit then Angela
leans in and whispers don't call me
anymore in her ear she smiles and goes
back to the SUV there's a flash of a
brownout while they're talking which is
a little bit weird if you listen to the
reporter he picks up at an earlier point
when the TV comes back on so even though
it seems like it's a live broadcast it's
almost like it was rewound Elliott is
coming up to the corner where mr. robot
is supposed to find the cab at first
he's trying to see where mr. robot is
going but then he realizes he already
knows since they are two parts of the
same person he approaches the cab with
caution and gets freaked out when the
cab driver knows his name we find out
that this is really the only English the
driver knows so he can't answer any of
Elliot's questions they sit there for a
minute until all the sudden Tyrell gets
in and gives the driver an address
Elliot is obviously freaked out by this
since he believes Tyrell is dead and he
starts to question whether it is real or
not he says there is no longer a
question of what he is seeing no he says
we know that is unreliable the real
question is what I'm not see Tyrell
seems off in a way that feels like it
was designed to make us wonder if he's
or not this could go two different ways
one one is that he isn't real at all
he's just another delusion and two is
that we are meant to wonder if he is
real in the same way that Eliot is he
says it's dangerous at their meeting but
they're safe because their partners have
proven to be very influential Eliot
tries to get the cab driver to tell him
if he sees Tyrell - but this doesn't
work since he doesn't understand English
he keeps going and starts freaking out
and Tyrell tries to calm him down but in
the end they end up getting kicked out
of the cab Tyrell says that he knows
that you know Elliott's under a lot of
stress and that he's been under a lot of
stress - he then says he has something
to show him he realizes Elliot has no
idea what he's talking about and he
asked him if he really doesn't remember
anything after that he tells him the
dark army contacted him to say the
stage-two was ready and he knows that
when Elliot sees it he will it'll make
him really happy from there Elliot
relaxes somewhat and they walk off
together and the episode ends so I
really like this episode while I was
watching it but I was a little
disappointed that we didn't get to see
part two right away I wrote a lot of
people saying that it brought up more
questions than it answered but I have to
respectfully disagree about that I mean
it didn't fly - I'll answer much but the
story did move ahead in a major way
for example Pryce laid out his eat corn
strategy so we could understand it and
by the end of the episode we see that
it's going through also Joanna got what
she wanted the location of the phone
that was calling her and she's basically
on her way to where it's at we don't
know where she's going or what she's
gonna find but I feel pretty confident
that we're gonna see that next week in
the same fashion we found out who the
people who picked Angela up on the train
were working for branded the scenes with
the young girl and White Rose didn't
clear up what's been happening at the
Washington Township plant the whole
experience at the house seems to have
lied to Angela being safe let's not
forget that she was headed to turn
herself in to the FBI in the last
episode and at least for now that's not
happening anymore the whole Tyrell thing
is tricky he appears to be alive but
Elliot isn't sure if Elliot isn't sure
then we're not sure because he is our
unreliable narrator you have to admit
it's exciting that he learned how to be
the silent observer but what that's all
gonna mean is pretty uh pretty much
err personally my gut instinct is that
Tyrell is alive even though the evidence
kind of contradicts it I basically think
that scene was just making it unclear to
put us in the same place Elliott was it
he could be dead of course and he could
be Elliot's new alter based on his grief
over killing him but I'm not ready to go
there yet
either way we should get confirmation in
the second half of the episode when
Joanna shows up wherever the phone is
the rest of what I'm gonna talk about
it's gonna have some spoilers so if you
don't want to know about the episode 12
trailer or what we know about the
shooting from slowing down the footage
go ahead and stop watching now while we
don't get confirmation about the
shooting what Dom says confirms what we
already thought about a survivor like I
mentioned last week I can't see how
Cisco survived being shot in the head
but you can see pretty clearly and you
slow the video down so this would mean
that Darlene is now in FBI custody
dogs not gonna stay in bed until next
season so let's hope we see who she is
interviewing next week and find out more
about it then in the trailer we see
mostly Elliott and Tyrell and we get a
shot where all three are standing
together with mr. robot two and the
voiceover we hear Tyrell say are you
ready to go look at what we accomplished
I'm not gonna speculate on what they're
doing there but it appears that it you
know we're gonna find out confirmation
you know related to stage two so it's
all three of them that are together that
I think that also means that we'll get
some more answers about what mr. robot
was up to in general the coolest thing I
noticed in the trailer is what looks
like a scene with mr. robot and Tyrell
that was from season 1 only when we see
it this time Elliott isn't mr. robots
place I'm hoping this means we'll get a
good idea of what happened in those
three days that Elliott can't remember
some things will definitely remain
unanswered and some of the crazy
theories going on will probably stay
unconfirmed I don't think we will know
exactly what's going on at Washington
Township by the end of the you know the
episode or the season and I'm not sure
that we'll have a good idea exactly
what's gonna happen between Dom or
Darlene but like I said I really liked
this episode and then I loved it when I
thought about it afterwards couldn't
really put it into words at the time but
I read an interview with Cora Donna on
The Hollywood Reporter website where
where the interviewer did a really good
job of it in one of the questions he
asked if
Angela in the room was the type of scene
that should be broken down to analyze
every little detail or was it more about
experience in that sensation of dread
and discomfort that she was going
through this was sort of the same thing
I was thinking about with the cab in the
scene with Elliot and Tyrell were we
supposed to get clues from this really
awkward and uncomfortable experience
Angela has with whiterose or where he
meant to feel uneasy like she does core
answers that there are a couple of
things going on in the scene the first
is that the questions are meant to find
out how malleable Angela is and test her
empathy as whiterose already told us the
second is that it is a roomful of
reminders that time is fleeting
you have the now-extinct rotary phone in
the Commodore 64 and of course the fish
tank that's losing water in the back so
I think we can take most of what
whiterose says at face value and for now
we don't need to know why the plan is
important to her I mean it that's not to
say that I don't want to know because I
definitely do but as far as where the
story is at what's more important is
that she can get Angela to believe in
what she's doing let's not forget that
we're an active participant in the story
as well there are a bunch of crazy
theories going around that involve time
travel androids artificial intelligence
augmented beings and so on and so forth
well I think it's fun to speculate I'm
getting a little bit tired of following
them at this point I mean it's just a
little bit too much there's not I mean
all of them have a little bit of
something that you could point to to say
maybe but there's really not great
evidence for any of them besides the
fact that people really want them to
come true I like the Easter eggs which I
mean they add a lot of enjoyment for me
but I really love the story and the
characters too
I mean I think Sam st. Massimo has
created something that's good on
multiple levels so I'm just trying to
sit back and enjoy the story for what it
is at this point I could say that if it
goes sci-fi that it would ruin it for me
but the truth is that but the truth is
is that it's really more about not
wanting it to change because I like
sci-fi I mean I'm not against it at all
the bottom line is that if Sam can land
the plane it doesn't really matter how
we get there I will definitely be poring
over every detail along the way because
it's just routine at this point but I'm
going to be trying to avoid getting too
attached to one particular outcome what
drew me in originally was Elliot's
struggle with
inability to connect and his difficulty
in trusting himself when it came to
reality he's a pretty good unreliable
narrator after all and if the writers
know where everything is going then
that's really enough for me so that's
what we're at and I'm super excited for
the finale let me know what you guys
think is coming next in the comments and
please like the video if you found it
interesting subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already and if you like
george RR martin and Game of Thrones
stuff check out my other videos too I'm
doing a book giveaway for subscribers so
check out one of those videos to learn
more thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon